[Musique]
cette musique cette mélodie l'ancien
organise de la basilique de saulieu
aurait adoré pouvoir la jouer mais
touché par la maladie de parkinson
il doit se résoudre à seulement l'écouté
ça me procure un bonheur renouvelé à
chaque fois que je regarde
quelquefois je ne le regarde pas pour
avoir le plaisir de regarder dix minutes
après
d'ailleurs je pense je conseille aux
gens qui veulent voir l'ordre de
s'avancer jusqu'ici dans la nef de ne se
retourne et qu'à ce moment là
[Musique]
cet instrument l'homme de 70 ans le
connais bien il en jouait ici depuis les
années 1960
maintenant un nouvel organisme a pris le
relais ce que je crois que prévu un
marché de l'or pour le 22 mai pour le
gala de musique le vainqueur biya pas
d'horaires c'est toute la journée toute
la nuit jusqu'à plus soif
chaque statue chaque détail de la
basilique
daniel corps d'un les connaît par coeur
il est fait découvrir aux touristes et
surtout visiter pour ses chapiteaux du
12e siècle quand on regarde
attentivement et qu'on prend le temps de
les regarder
vous avez tout l'aspect biblique
liturgique et ensuite vous avez aussi
l'aspect de la sculpture la finesse de
la sculpture
[Musique]
ces vitraux à eux datent du 19e siècle
il montre notamment l'arrivée à saulieu
du prêtre andoche donnera son nom au
monument accompagné de son diacre
tierces
aujourd'hui la basilique ag de 900 ans
et haute de 42 mètres est bien connu par
tous les habitants
elle représente la ville de saulieu la
première chose qu'on voit quand on vient
on arrive dans ce haut lieu
mon père et dc est originaire d'ici et
nous nous avons fait tous les baptêmes
de nos enfants ici c'est merveilleux
baptêmes et mariages et aux haïtiens la
mettez ce combat à l'intérieur ça prend
des photos ça regarde cette église
construite au 12e siècle sur les ruines
d'une abbaye françoise la parcourt tous
les jours et cette fidèle paroissienne y
tient beaucoup
c'est un peu de ma seconde maison s'est
hissé de résidence principale la mienne
et puis l'église c'est un jeu agréable
un lieu de paix on entre ici on oublie
un petit peu ces soucis aussi on est
dans un état d'esprit différent
un état d'esprit qui anime les croyants
ici depuis 900 ans et qui ne devrait pas
s'arrêter
cette année la basilique a été classé
parmi les sites clunisiens
[Musique]